they'll complete a suspended game with
the marlins this afternoon this game
started on april the 11th 142 days ago
marcus strowman threw nine pitches gave
up a hit got an out through two balls to
aguilar strowman will not continue the
game from this point it'll be taiwan
walker farrow at second two down counts
a ball and a strike to anderson walker
to the belt comes home and andy bounces
one right back to the pitcher off the
glove of walker though will roll out
toward the shortstop position and
everybody's going to be safe
swinging a miss and walker strikes out
sanchez yes as i said keith we're all a
little slow starting today so the top of
the first inning ends some four and a
half months later and the mets have come
to bat with those scores
so for eliezer hernandez this is
considered a start
slash the other way by nimmo that's a
fair ball going down into the corner
and brandon to second takes a hard turn
there and he'll hold with a lead-off
double
15th double of the year for brandon nemo
and landora drops down a bun hernandez
is going to have to go to first with it
and they'll go on the books as a
sacrifice
one to three moving nimo over to third
oh and two to dom
and it's at his feet
it did he did
and so he'll go to first base and
that'll bring alonzo up with runners at
the corners 1-2 to alonso a swing and a
miss
he gets the strikeout
and there are now two away
good look at said slider 79 miles an
hour off the outside edge 21 pitches in
this first for hernandez trying to work
around
the first and third situation
and he will do just that jazz
and those nifty spikes makes the play
mcneil retired
and the mets strand two scoreless
afterwards
jazz lines one fair down the left field
line dom smith will chase it down
jazz into second base with a lead off
double
yeah nice piece of hitting by jazz
here's miguel rojas
miggy line drive base hit left field
jazz is coming around
the throw is off the mark
and jazz is in to score rojas with an
rbi
well miggy rowe getting it done once
again line drive in the left it's the
major league debut of brian de la cruz
his first at bat in the big leagues as
he was acquired from the astros july
30th had not played in the big leagues
on april 11 when this game began and
that is dropped in to left center field
here comes rojas around third
it's cut off
and de la cruz is safe at second
with his second first major league hit a
little bit of a merry-go-round here in
the second inning for the marlins
swinging the miss and alfaro struck out
for the second out
2-2 swung out and missed strike three
they don't need a score card other than
to put a k in there to retire the side
three strikeouts for walker
nothing in two on conforto who takes one
right down broadway
now called strike three laser hernandez
has his second strikeout one away
1-0 pounded down to first nice pick on a
short hop by aguilar he waits waits and
then steps on the bag to get vr two men
away that's all by design aguilar is an
absolute character and now aguilar just
i can't believe this aguilar has been
mouthing into the mets dugout i think at
lindor and he just gave him a thumbs
down
so aguilar reads the papers too
one-two pitch is a slider down and he
offered at it he's down on strikes they
ring up walker punch out number two in
the inning number three in the game
who's now hitting 362.
did he go around he did strike three
one two coming and he chases for strike
three so back-to-back strikeouts
el faro slugs one out to center and nimo
has it lined up
let's step onto the warning track to get
it side retired first one two three
inning for taiwan walker still
two-nothing miami
jackson to strike out his first time
and is hit by the pitch
brown ball up the middle of base hit for
b.a
jackson makes the turn and heads toward
third
marlins will have him on the corners
here with one out
and he pops one up
they are coming in from third to call up
on the mound and he makes the catch
that's not easy
walker was trying to
gauge it and it took vr a while to
figure out how far away from him it was
and he had to go up the hill to get it
man on first and third jazz doubled his
first time then a fly ball to center 2-2
from walker
and jazz with a fly ball out to right
center field look frustrated off the bat
but i think he'll be happy with it that
one hops up and over the wall
alex jackson will score the mets catch a
break because andy's got to stop at
third with the automatic double for jazz
three two coming
struck him out
there's a big strikeout for taiwan
walker 3-2 slaughtered again rojas for
his sixth strikeout
that's with two hits so far off this
right-hander the r smacks this one deep
to center field forget that that ball is
way out of here number 16 for jonathan
villard he gets the meds on the board in
the fifth inning what a poke for vr
again the 3-2
and it's lined to the right center field
for a base hit
terrific turn it back for j.d davis as a
pinch-hitter
fouled off the slider got a fastball to
hit and the mets will get the tying run
to the play to the fifth davis at first
and one out and looking to bunt gets a
beauty down anderson with a bare hand
play
and he's out oh wow
is he a perfectly executed but and we'll
see if the mets challenge the call if
they want to immediately i think he beat
it
and the mets have challenged the call
nemo certainly did beat that and we
should get the call in a moment and he
is safe and so it's a fun hit for nemo
he did
he tried to hold and he did ball four
that is the first walk of the day issued
by hernandez
the 3-2 alonso swings and misses he
chased the slider out of the zone and
eliezer hernandez leaves him loaded in
the fifth what an escape
pitch to jackson they pitch out nearly a
strike that then
sneaks into center field sierra will now
head to third
what an odd turn of events that was
looked like a the mets wanted a pitch
out mazika was up and
out of the crouch the pitch missed the
outside corner by a couple of inches and
not only does sierra get to second
but he gets to third
three-two pitch to jackson way outside
he tried to slide or he walks them
smartly will have him on the corners
payoff pitch coming from hembree to
aguilar
here it is
lifted
shallow right coming in conforto
nobody's going to get there mcneal and
conforto crash into one another alonso
picks it up jackson scores behind sierra
and aguilar drives home two
but we keep an eye on mcneil on the
ground in right field
i think he's gonna be okay
his jazz lines one center field another
base hit for jazz so a three-hit game
for him now jazz continues to hit
grounds a double play ball mcneal to
lindor back to first four six three
double play that'll work
three two coming and cisco is on with a
walk so the minutes have a base runner
in the ninth
and then we'll go to the top of the
order in brandon nimmo
he launches one to deep right field back
goes sanchez for a look that ball is out
of here
brandon nemo cuts the lead in half with
a 2-1 homer his fifth home run of the
season and now it's five to three that's
the veteran left hand to richard bleyer
2-2
lined left field line that's going to be
fair into the corner
dom digging for third
alonzo to second
and the mitz of the tying runs in
scoring position with javi baez coming
up dylan floro the right-hander who is
going to face javier baez for the first
time in his career javi grounds one on
the left side deep in the hole is rojas
his desperation throw not in time a run
comes in and the tying one goes to third
an infield hit for bias to drive in
smith to make it five to four
alonso the tying run at third bae is the
winning run at first two out
and conferno slashes one the other way
base head that ties the game alonzo in
by sticking for third it's kicked by a
furl here comes fires trying to score he
scores and the mets win it
turn those thumbs around holly fires
races home with a winning run and the
mets win it six to five
you